professor relson we are doing our series
on the most important thing you can do
science or something that you know you
couldn't do now when we got for Aslan's
very well I think my most important
thing we're going to sort of share this
discussion still banging on because I
think we very much agreed that one of
the most powerful concepts constructs in
computer science is just the idea of a
pointer one of the uses of pointers as
easiest to understand is in linked lists
we're going to use a Lego to illustrate
linked lists I know that some of you are
demon programmers and could take it if I
just ran through a program with you but
I think a lot of you who are beginners
perhaps might appreciate having a more
pictorial introduction to linked lists
so a great mental expansion and I have
developed a Lego model of building lists
we want to talk about and we'll
gradually introduce the elements of this
as we go along but the first thing to
say is that pointers are pieces of I
don't know what they are in Lego
firemen's hoses or connectors or
whatever they're called that is a
pointer of some sort in order to bring
this home and make it more concrete I've
got to say well what are we linking
together and once again I mean this has
been referred to in Brian Kernighan
thing about associative arrays he
pointed off to singly linked lists and
each of the elements within every singly
linked list contained a string what I'm
going to start with is basically piece
of Lego underneath a small section of C
coding I'm going to go through this very
carefully
and those of you who aren't demon
programmers don't get panicked about it
I'll tango very slowly and explain to
you what's happening this is what I am
going to call a thing whenever you look
later on and say what is that gray
baseplate doing what does it signify
gray base plate means it's a thing what
are the components of a thing
well a red box sitting on top of the
thing holds a string of characters and
again we're going to follow up with the
idea of things you might buy for a
barbecue burgers tips line stuff like
that but because it's a singly linked
list the other box sitting within the
structure is going to point off to the
next thing along in this singly linked
list if that's a thing then the only bit
of programming I'm going to do today
honest this is it is to just show you
how this would be declared in the C
language I'm using a type def
declaration because I just want to be
able to use the shorthand of theme a bit
like int instead of saying int Shawn
semicolon Shawn is an integer and can
have contours I just want to go fake
thing Shawn but you're not to be able to
make that abbreviation and to cut the
clutter a lot I have to give what's
called a tied this a definition of what
a structure of type thing really is and
all it's saying here if you look at it
is char star item now what that is
saying this is again those of you
familiar with C will know it's a
standard C way of saying it's a pointer
to a char apparently but actually they
cheat a bit because it's not just a
pointer to a single character it can be
a pointer to a great long string of
characters just charming character char
is short for character yes some people
call it cars a little Colie char but is
basically if you point it the first
character in a string then your pointer
the whole thing goes you just step along
it sequentially and here for the blue
box in my model I've got to say well how
do I point it the next thing along in my
list well I hope you can see there's a
sort of bit of recursion in the
definition here but the compiler knows
you can do things like this and doesn't
panic you've got a struct underscore
thing inside here referring back to the
struct underscore saying what is saying
is that this thing I'm calling next
within the structure is a pointer to the
next
so what are these things known as then
is item and next they're called
members in C next is also a member in
other languages you'll find these
internal identify a zero within a
structure called different things I mean
in alcohol 68 where I started they were
called fields of the structure those are
just so that you can pick out the
components of your structure and
remember the overall package of a
pointer to the next one a red box which
means I can contain a string of
arbitrary size mount the whole thing up
on a piece of grey Lego and the whole
thing is a thing we've got the basic
building block then what we need to
start building together linked lists now
some of you are going to say hey come on
you're glossing over actuality because
obviously this next member field is
going to have a pointer in it to the
next one of these things but you haven't
said that inside the string box you
can't just put a string inside an
address box it might not be big enough
to hold
supercalifragilistic expialidocious yeah
quite right
those of you know no one know that
within this box that contains a string
you will have well it says so here you
must create yourself enough space to
hold the string and point at it we draw
a Dale over that for the moment just
imagine that it doesn't matter what the
string is burgers zucchini whatever we
can create enough space in the red box
to hold that spring make an identifiable
I'm going to put out the code for this
program and any subsequent ones in the
usual way available to you in in C I'll
try and get my indentation so it doesn't
make those are you care passionately how
these things my views will be there'll
be indentation Wars some people will
love the way I've done in other people
will hate it but we'll live with that
but yes the idea of this going through
this model purely with Lego is that if
you then get hold of the program look
back at the video try and follow all the
things I'm doing and say what how does
the
program do that and see if you can
understand as we go along I wish in many
ways I've thought about trying to do
this when I was teaching link this to so
do undergrads I think it might have
helped some of them who are very
pictorial in the way they want to look
at things
once we've declared at the top of our C
program that this whole thing is called
a thing I can then say later on in the
program if I wanted to thing Shawn just
like saying int sure but this is the
thing okay we haven't filled in your
likes and dislike sure what's your
favorite stuff at barbeque sausages
sausage is so that of course is the
barbecue item that Shawn likes best now
if I've named my thing which I haven't
given this an identifier name I can say
things like Shawn dot item equals quotes
sausages and how works fine because if
you give an explicit string of
characters in C it will at compile time
find the space to hold that for you so
that should work okay and there's also
no prizes for guessing that perhaps for
cleanliness I want to fill in what the
next field of Shawn is and there is a
standard way of saying it's the zero
pointer it points nowhere it's called
Neal it's gone no not being filled in
yet but you've got filling with
something so you fill it in with no a
stage beyond that is to say theme star P
now if you're happy that star item
within the structure means pointed to a
string of characters then it follows
that the type of P is pointer to think
so I haven't filled anything in here yet
this contains nothing this box but I
could overwrite it with a pointer to
Shawn if I wanted to do that
okay so we will be developing quite a
lot the idea that we don't necessarily
deal always directly with things we
stand back one level and we
use pointers to things it makes good
sense because within the list of
structures we're developing as you know
the next field is of type pointer to a
thing I guess at this stage perhaps to
make this a bit more concrete we could
turn our attention now over to the Lego
and in that infuriating way that they do
on home help do-it-yourself programs on
TV I'm going to say here's one I
prepared already the idea in this
particular linked list of barbecue items
is that there are strings inside each of
these red boxes as we've discussed and
these strings of characters correspond
to things you might want on the barbecue
but we are so neat and tidy we want to
keep these in alphabetical order so look
at this the string content in that red
box says beer chips Pizza slaw wine so
don't forget these are the contents of
the boxes the member name of each box is
all same it's always the item part of
the particular thing you're on at the
moment and the pointer here is the next
part of that mark but it's called
beautifully set up look every one of
your next boxes really does point to the
start address of the next thing all the
way down they're all in alphabetical
order but the one aspect we didn't
mention which is vital is that you must
set up a pointer to the head of the
linked list if you don't have that you
can't reference anything what we're
saying here is it's not part of linked
list processing in general to give each
of these things structures its own name
I mean young I could call them Shawn
Dave Steve Mike and Robert or something
like that but no mouse too short I'd run
out of names no keep them all in order
but just retain one pointer that tells
you what is the lead item in there
so this start pointer look at the color
coding it's blue so it's a thing star or
as we used to say I was get a reference
to a thing you jump onto the pointer any
of the start address of the thing and
inside that
you can say give me the item give me the
next and so on but the big question now
is it's all beautiful but suppose
actually I was told to get some burgers
but they didn't have them available at
the first supermarket I went in so have
to go somewhere else and get some
burgers and unfortunately Bryan or Sean
has made this list up already so
determinately keeping it alphabetic if I
prepare over here a new thing with
burgers ready to be put in how do I
Traverse down this list find out where
it belongs alphabetically and get it to
work from the back and fiddle with the
pointers and Link it in quick chat will
show you that burgers belongs after beer
but before chips therefore what you need
is a probe to look inside each of these
structures and to tell you what is
inside there in terms on the item field
now I can't use start of the probe
if I move that away from the head of the
list and sunk I'll never find that
wretched list ever again you mustn't you
start as your roving pointer but what I
can't do just like the thing called P I
devote let's call this P for the pointer
if I first of all copy over the contents
of start into P which is also of type
reference to thing and I hope you'll all
agree that what will happen is I've now
got this thing called P is pointing at
exactly the same structure of the head
of the list as start is so hope I've
gotten a finger power here too there you
go you start with P up here and you say
what's the item within that thing I'm
pointing at now it says beer so burgers
goes after beer then move that from
there to there and use it as a probe to
ask what is the item entry network chips
I needs beer 11 chips so you can see
here you've got a bit of a problem with
a singular linked list if you move the
pointer too far you end up with chips
but you say
but I want to insert it before chips but
after beer I want to be back at this
address so what I'm saying is it's
pretty possible to do it you've got to
be very careful you've got to come in
you could have set up on the beer then
you very carefully got to take a look at
this next field and say should have flow
that pointer see what's in the next
wheel box you can do that is fine but be
so careful that it doesn't contain nil
no it could be a very short list it
could be that there's only one item in
it
and right down the bottom here this
thing that looks like something from
Angry Birds denotes no and if you use
start trying to follow the null pointer
your program will go bang and say
segmentation violation well that's fine
but it needs some careful programming
but it can be done and I will give you a
solution that does it just that way next
thing you've got to sort of say to
yourself though is when I found where I
want to be how do i bind in the new
thing well the actual construction
process if you like putting a new thing
once you've discovered that burgers
needs to go in here somewhere
is to do this you've got to well use an
extra long pointer here which points to
our new lis created thing and we are
then going to take the old pointer that
was in there and put it as going from
here to here so look we've done it we go
beer follow the pointer to a thing
that's got burgers let's move that out
of the way follow the pointer to a thing
that's called chips so we've inserted
burgers so it's just pointer
manipulation once you've discovered
where you are what you need in this and
it's really frustrating
you need to give your finger in two
places or you need two fingers let's put
it that way you want to remember the one
you just looked at you want to take a
look at the next one and say yes it's in
between those two we've done it we
patched in our new thing for burgers so
let me just sort of summarize some of
the problems and obsessively keep
checking for new obsessively if you
dereference that
you're dead and that brings into
question certain special cases what
happens if I want to insert something at
the end of a list where nil is parked
there already I've got to be very
careful there well suppose I wanted put
a zucchini or something in at the bottom
below why that might be a problem even
worse problem potentially might be if I
wanted to put something in at the head
of the list a head was there already I
mean under those circumstances what
you'd be saying is something beginning
with a shorn abakada to make guacamole
with if we want to put avocado here then
what you will have to do is to create a
new thing there and move that two points
avocado and then make avocados ruling
point of that one so this is avocado
that would be start of your list now and
you'd have a internal one to complete it
going from here to here now here is a
big problem because you'd better get
this right because notice you have
actually altered stars what I was saying
all along with the careful start
it's your pointer to the head of the
list but if you get something like
avocados that has to be the new head of
the list then you must make sure that
the start pointing gets updated another
special case there's got to be put in
your code so be obsessive about checking
for now can you cope with things
inserted at the head of very start of
the list nicely can you cope with
putting a zucchini at the end is it all
nice and clean you'll see in the
solution I gave you that there has to be
a lot of special case checking to get
all of this right but on the other hand
you can make it work
but you will in general need some sort
of roving pointer or pointers moving
down the list to check what you're
pointing at and what the next one is now
if you look at that code and say oh it's
yucky it's horrible can't you do any
better than that
it's not easy however there is a top
secret trick which actually makes it so
much easier to do that have to be a
separate video sorry to leave with
cliffhangers folks but it's becoming
almost a computer file tradition now
isn't it so what would make life a lot
easier
is instead of just having star I mean we
can't do away with it but we've got it
but you know it's a blue thing it points
to a structure of type thing is if we
introduce the concept of a pointer to a
pointer to a thing and this is what a
green box signifies I've got some extra
long linkage here I'm going to put that
on there so I hope you're all happy
because this is really doing type theory
elementary types of theory in a way that
would make my functional colleagues
blench but I'll try not to say anything
too obviously untrue you'll have to
agree with me but if the contents of a
blue box is a reference to us thing then
if you step one beyond it you're
referring to a ref thing or the things
dark for dinner so the contents of the
green box would be a ref ref thing or in
C notation a thing star star similar
programmers among you will say out come
on this is just typesafe nonsense
they're all pointers just mess about
with them do what you want with them and
don't make any mistakes
now what I like about C is it's a nice
halfway house it gives you a bit of
typesafe capability it does distinguish
between a pointer to a thing and a
pointer to a pointer to a thing and
makes you very carefully get the level
of you're pointing correct but what can
be revealed in the future is that that
simple trick of this thing containing a
pointer to a pointer can solve a huge
island Republic
here is the definition or one possible
definition of RAC in the lambda calculus
and this is what's known as the Y
Combinator and if you look at this when
it looks like a jumble of symbols but
it's actually very similar to loop if we
look back to see the definition of loop